on va le rappeler c'est par vous qui
êtes un vécu cette situation qui ravit
c'est la société dans laquelle vous dis
qui a dîné avec
fanny on part en maraude c'est à dire
qu'on va aller rentrer dans la gare est
bon les personnes sans abri qui dort new
kiss on voit mal tourné en train de
faire la manque on va aller juste voir
comment ils vont aujourd'hui voir s'ils
ont besoin d'elle au niveau de leur
santé certaines personnes on les connaît
d'autres pas et donc on va rentrer en
contact
[Musique]
en chatte et monsieur
on ne les infirmières cabinet pas mis en
avant première ci je sais qu'ici vous a
plu
[Musique]
avec fanny on s'est rendu compte durant
le stage durant la première année de
travail qui avait un manque au niveau de
la santé pour les personnes à l'abri à
liège et qui avait pas de personnel
médical en rue et donc le problème sans
abri est un problème qui me touchait
particulièrement parce que je trouve ça
on est en 2021 en belgique on devrait
plus avoir de sans abri
pouvait dans la garde dormait ou
votre santé parents comme un
moyen vous avez là d'abord tu vois
on va travailler avec les priorités la
personne et pas nos priorités en tant
que soignant parce que moi jamais forcer
la personne à faire quoi que ce soit
donc ça va être au fil de discussion
l'expliqué écoute moi je suis pas
inquiet par rapport à ta santé je suis
inquiet par rapport à une hygiène etc on
va chanter sur des oeufs parfois mais au
fur et à mesure on y arrive et la
personne un jour voir un déclic a été
bloquée aujourd'hui seulement jour où je
ris je les suis et je vais me soigner
on regarde beaucoup devant chaque quai
il ya le petit renfoncement et donc ça
les endroits où ils semaine parce qu'ils
sont à l'abri du vent
[Musique]
j'appelle votre lit matters vélo médical
d'une un peu et je reviens ici avec
fanny la semaine prochaine vous
je faut bien noter que les personnes qui
vivent rue balle à leur santé
psychologique est très très très fragile
si ce sont des personnes qui sont très
vulnérables et donc clients aussi
énormément besoin d' écoute simplement
généralement on passe tous à côté d'eux
en leur faveur à peine un regard est
donc juste et cette oreille attentive et
cette écoute hyper importante et pour
nous écouter est en soins prenez soin de
vous
oui à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
quoiqu'il à la primaire je peux me
renseigner
[Musique]
microsoft cela n'est plus possible
mais voilà moi je t'aime il n'y a rien
de plus naturel
y perd important parce que c'est des
personnes qui vivent rue qui sont
souvent qu'ils se sentent en tout cas
abandonné par tout le monde abandonné
par la société qui sont dans une
situation indigne et donc on va le
rappeler c'est pas vous qui êtes indigne
cette situation qui a abaissé la société
dans laquelle on dit qu'il ya ding vous
vous êtes quelqu'un de bien pour
toujours avait vu par plaisir parce
qu'on peut leur dire bonjour on peut
leur profit ce qui ne va pas comprendre
vraiment avec ça ni que prend les
problèmes de santé à la halle aux
ressources va permettre de réduire ce
taux de morbidité parce qu'il faut
savoir que à liège chaque année il y
entre 20 et 30 personnes qui décèdent
des suites de leur vie en rue avec une
moyenne d'âge de 45 ans donc je sais pas
si on sent les 45 ans et 20 à 30
personnes qui décèdent chaque année pour
moi et pour fanny c'est un chiffre qui
est inadmissible
[Musique]